Mẹ có đêm đứa bây giờ này cho hai đứa này
Dọng ông chưa ước đó
Cứ có thể ước khi đó
Dích chí tầm hộ này hả?
Còn ước sông ở phíang phía lương thật game
Tò là người gơm bị hứt
Tà tối đây để bước chú gong
Dên xưa sau thật team
Nơi bà phút của chiến gà
Chúng kiểu bột game
Hạ phát tầm hả?
Nhưng như gặp bóng trong những cực kênh của hộ nha không này luôn
Tà đi thôi
Để không nói gian
Hãy giữa có xa ớy ớy
Hay bây giờ cũng tạo
Giự Ki một đồng tự tụt
Điều không xuyên sở đến sế quá tay diều đã dưới
And then giống này có nắng
Dạy
Điều dừng tự mở đi
Mắt kẻ có một nơi
Cực đi hiểu lắm
Chắc giờ mẹ đáng lắm
Bù đồng đất đối
Trúc ca không có hình cháng ngủ
Điều tụt sao đúng không?
Để nói bơi đứa con đồng tự tụt đồng tự tụt đối
Cảm ơn
Dạng thách bắt ông giao quốc tíu.
Thì rồi.
Bộ cường không thấy như gì vậy?
Sơn thì cường là mất dỷ.
Cảm ơn dỷ.
Con có biết là dẫn tới đau hết.